welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and our infinity Saga rewatched
left us with a 360-degree God view of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and thank
God I can't pivot this camera 360
degrees because these blue dungeon walls
are coated in yarn and trivia notes and
sexy doodles other stuff that wouldn't
pass a blacklight test as we've been
trying to extend this Marvel timeline
further into the future I realize
something is off its loyal suspicion
that our reality is not what it should
be that some inflection point derailed
us from our rightful destiny into this
darkest timeline that we now find
ourselves in now yes that also applies
to the you know outside world but I'm
only certified to discuss fictional
cinematic universes one year ago Kevin
Feige announced Marvel's phase 4 plan
kicking off with stories like Black
Widow and Falcon Winter Soldier on
Disney Plus and we're all like yeah cool
but you know we just saw far from home
with what seemed to be pretty clear
Fantastic Four Easter eggs so like where
the piece of Fantastic Four where's doom
where's the mutants where is Galactus we
know you got him cameo yeah with one
year of history to look back on it I
think we can now identify the trajectory
of the MCU and there was no way the
announced phase four plan was the
original plan everything we've seen
tells us that the studio had a very
different timeline mapped out but they
had to abandon it after one event
changed everything and I'm not talking
about social distancing related delays
those are part of it but the real
inflection points are always less
obvious you know like Biff being given
the sports Almanac by his older self
before they you know made out in this
car let's suit up and quantum nanotech
and boost up with orange slices as we
explore Marvel's abandoned timeline
okay let's rewind the clock back six
years to 2014 the most important year
for Marvel Studios because it reached a
critical nexus crossroads see in 2014
Marvel released its two best films
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
guardians of the galaxy both game
changers in different ways that gave the
studio two diverging narrative paths
forward within which to set up their
upcoming stories in Phase three I will
call these paths the Bucky path and the
rocket paths the Bucky paths was
introduced in Captain America Winter
Soldier directed by the Russo brothers
written by Markus and McFeely whom I
have nicknamed Eminem because they kind
of look like this guys and I realized
that has got to be some of you via
Oh generated subtitles folks I would
never blame in games plotholes of
marshall mathers that man was miles
ahead of us on a stand curve now I call
it the Bucky path because Bucky's return
and Winter Soldier locked in the MC news
interconnectivity history and fanservice
flavor like his rage over the lies he's
been told his inner conflict between his
tech and his soul these are the themes
embraced by all earthbound ensues
stories that follows Civil War
homecoming Black Panther ant-man and the
wasp
Captain Marvel endgame far from home
when Yuri watch them it's actually weird
how much screen time Bucky gets in these
movies almost as if Marvel is using him
as a grounding force to remind us what
planet were on now the rocket path was
introduced in James Gunn's guardians of
the galaxy I call it that because more
than the others rocket represents the
whole identity crisis of all of these
stories in a vast cosmos and an endless
multiverse who are you
why do you matter Doctor Strange
guardians vol 2 thor ragnarok infinity
war these stories showcase broken freaks
wandering the universe in pursuit of a
connection and a purpose now the Bucky
path has been defined by realism all of
its Marvel's are grounded in Terran
ingenuity like stark tech Pym tech
wakandan tech the rocket path has been
defined by its absurdism it's not always
explained the wizardry is magical
spiritual cosmic Lovecraftian or douglas
adams's esque it all comes from
Asgardian or celestial origins now these
two paths crossed in infinity war the
precise moment the magical Asgardian
Bifrost delivered rocket directly into
the path of the soil of Wakanda the
setting that Bucky had spent all of his
time in
how much video Oh get that off now phase
three took Marvel firmly down the Bucky
path opening with the Russo directed
civil war with Bucky at the center of
that story and then culminating an end
game in which Bucky allowed his fellow
soldier to finally retire that was the
closing shot of that film but all signs
pointed to the rocket path being the way
forward afterward in phase four until it
wasn't so what happened well before we
continue thanks to bang energy for
sponsoring this video every can of bang
is 16 ounces it contains 300 milligrams
of caffeine it's sugar-free and a zero
calories and it tastes great with over
20 different flavors to choose from one
of those great flavors is pina colada
it tastes like that song that I would
sing but we don't the rights to it you
know about that married couple that
cheat on each other but with each other
and somehow that makes their marriage
better you get that full pina colada
flavor without your marriage falling
apart
and hey it picks you up with energy
energy you could actually use to you
know fix your marriage with your spouse
check out bang on Instagram you can get
25% off your order at bang and dash
energy calm when you use the code new
rockstars 25 there you can buy cans of
bang energy including their sweet tea or
cute coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang self and
again thanks to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using the code of new
rockstars 25 okay while Marvel phase 3
stuck more to the Buckey path you could
sense that the MCU was ready to break
free of Earth's atmosphere into the
rocket pack okay space rocket and his
fellow as guardians of the galaxy were
clearly the future of the cinematic
universe and then right after this far
from home ended with Nick Fury the man
always with one foot in reality now
barefoot in space so why would Marvel
then open phase 4 with a Winter Soldier
style spy thriller like Black Widow
character most of us associate with
being dead immediately followed by
another Bucky story in Falcon Winter
Soldier well it is because we are in the
wrong timeline folks bye guys original
plan was to kick off phase 4 not with
Black Widow but with
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 in May
2020
script was mostly finished the movie was
set start production and its release
would have been followed by Black Widow
either in July 2020 or November 2020 the
Russos moved on for the Marvel contracts
James Gunn and Taika Waititi were set up
to take their place as Marvel's go-to
storytellers expanding the MCU to even
wider limits tying in long-anticipated
yet admittedly a bit absurd figures like
Galactus and Silver Surfer while far
from home set up Nick Fury overseen
sword and Earth's orbit introducing the
Fantastic Four who almost certainly
seemed to be the new occupants of
Avengers towered now probably the Baxter
building in that movie with yeah Doctor
Doom probably being the ruler of that
subatomic city that they hid in the
quantum realm in a man the wasp that's
doctor dooms story in the classic
Fantastic Four comics and that's why
this is not really theory at this point
it's really just the obvious roadmap
that Marvel was laying for themselves
because you know as shocking as Thanos
to snap or Mysterio's bad guy nests were
those twists were really just pulled
directly from their best-known comic
storylines more often than not Marvel
sticks to the script written for them in
the comics so yeah this was our original
phase four timeline along with all the
other great titles announced at Comic
Con last year but with more of a clear
direction forward and that would set up
the future return to the Bucky path of
earthbound stories like Blade like the
mutants in Phase five the inflection
point that derailed this plan came late
in phase three right as these plans were
coming together in July 2018 without
warning an online hit campaign rose up
against James Gunn pressuring Disney to
fire him which they did until months
later when they realized the whole thing
was stupid and they rehired him but it
was too late James Gunn already signed
on to direct the Suicide Squad for
Warner Brothers and the guardian of the
galaxy vol 3 Caste Scheduled other
projects and then suddenly Marvel
Studios was without it's big cosmic
universe expanding kickoff to face board
they can no longer launch the future
with a crossover story to introduce the
dream titles that Feige long sought and
finally reacquired the box and so the
plan changed guardians vol 3 would be
pushed beyond 2020 to an insane six year
gap longer than the gap between any
other MCU sequel series and now phase
four would lead off with black widow and
falcon Winter Soldier
more Buckey path stories that probably
won't venture off world or off reality
leaving that rocket path to later titles
like one division loki multiverse
madness love and thunder now but good
news is this change timeline now means
we might get cool earthbound stories
like Secret Invasion rebooted mutants
blade a bit sooner than we would have
liked sure in a different life we should
have him for days the galaxy vol 3 by
now but absence of that there's room for
Marvel to explore one of the best comic
story lines in the MCU now of course the
timeline does went up and changed again
so now we're not gonna get anything to
the fall who knows what reality we're
living in just remember they can't move
all this stuff around super easily it's
a super connected cinematic universe
each story opens the door and paves the
way for the next chapter so bearing this
in mind the imagination runs wild with
the possibilities of what a Guardians 3
lead phase 4 could have looked like in
that abandoned timeline
you know if Twitter wasn't so stupid hey
which type of MCU film do you prefer the
Bucky type earthbound stories or the
Rocket type cosmic stories comment down
below follow me on instagram at EA buzz
followed me rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching
boom you looking for this
[Music]
e RI k that is my name